[Musique]
tous
d'autres spécimens qui sont rangés dans
les placards j'ai vraiment optimisé
toute la place que l'on avait de
disponible
les poils sont très très fragile tout ce
qui est petit petit parti les becs les
yeux le nez les oreilles c'est très très
fragile donc ça peut être forcément
cassé
[Musique]
mais
équipés de masques anti poussière
florence et victoria s'apprête à coiffer
la collection d'ursidés des milliers de
spécimens ont été restaurés depuis le
début des travaux les mammifères et près
de trois mille oiseaux que florence doit
préserver de la poussière et des
nuisances du chantier de transformation
il ya beaucoup de vibrations et il faut
absolument qu'on préserve un maximum
toutes nos toutes nos collections
qu'elle ne vienne pas à s'abîmer donc à
ce centre que choquer entre elles et
qu'elles viennent pas non plus à tomber
donc c'est très important qu'elle soit
bien bien conditionner bien stocker à
l'abri des vibrations
[Musique]
à trop humides ni trop chaud ni trop
froid
florence est aussi en charge de
l'hygrométrie des réserves provisoire
son activité de conservation préventive
est très minutieuse offert attention pas
s'accrocher et les grands bec les longs
que c'est beaucoup de boulot puis quand
vous les positionner à présent
positionnés à mais après faut faire
attention avec les manches par exemple
et mangent ces traîtres faut prendre son
temps faut pas aller dans la
précipitation
[Musique]
tu
john p avant j'étais l'agent d'accueil
donc je ne connaissais pas trop les
collections et là j'ai découvert
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de spécimens
de magnifiques spécimens et ça nous a
permis de refaire un inventaire vraiment
très très complet malgré toutes les
précautions un prédateur inattendu s'est
invitée dans les collections au début
des travaux
nous n'avions pas prévu que il y aurait
des ouvertures que non qu'on ne va pas
d'habitude et que les rats
s'infiltrerait par ses ouvertures et
remonterait jusque dans les réserves
provisoire où étaient stockées les
oiseaux alors ils ont attaqué les ailes
en majorité n'est pas tout si ils ont
rongé les pattes des rares ont été in
fine est capturé et congelés en vue
d'une exposition futur mais l'ennemi
numéro 1 des collections ça reste la
mite friande des animaux naturalisés la
teigne contraint tout le personnel à
travailler en milieu confiné
des conditions de travail drastique qui
seront bien meilleures en 2020 à
l'ouverture du nouveau muséum